The motion of
objects in space is
governed by the
universal law of gravity.
So let's consider
how this works.
We have two objects
here, object one and two.
And that could be two
planets or two asteroids
or two white dwarfs,
black holes, any kind
of objects you can imagine.
And they are mutually
attracted by each other due to
gravitation.
So we have a gravitational
force and we label this as F.
And this is the
force on object one
due to the interaction between
the bodies one and two.
And here we have a
force on object two
due to the interaction
between objects one and two.
And the objects are separated
by a distance r1, 2.
Now, we want to derive the
universal law of gravitation.
How are we going
to go about that?
Well, Newton figured
out a while ago
that it is proportional to the
masses of objects one and two.
So this one has a mass
m2 and this one has m1.
And it is also proportional
to the square of the distance
between the two objects.
Now, we need to do
one more consideration
and then we can derive this.
We need to actually--
well, first,
we need to pick
some kind of origin
from where we are considering
these two objects to be.
And this object here goes
from the origin to there
and we call this r1.
And then we have
here r2, which also
means that the distance here
between object one and two
is r1, 2.
And actually, we know
from vector decomposition
that r1, 2 equals r2 minus r1.
So just this minus this
gives us this distance here.
Now, if we want to write
down the universal law
of gravitation, there's a
magnitude component to it
and we also need a direction.
And we haven't yet chosen
a coordinate system.
We could, of course,
choose our usual way
of placing the i-hat
direction in the x-direction
and the j-hat coordinate
in the y-direction.
But when we deal with the
universal law of gravitation,
it's actually better to
adopt a slightly different
coordinate system.
Everything in space
usually orbits one another
so it's much better to think
in a radial direction rather
than just normal
Cartesian coordinates.
And so in this case, we're going
to choose an r-hat vector which
gives us a radial direction and
we're going to do this here.
So this is going to be our
r-hat direction on object two.
And here, we have an
r-hat direction 2, 1.
One And we're going to
come back to the r-hat unit
vectors later.
For now, we can just write here
quickly down the definition
for a unit factor.
So our r-hat 1,2 is, of course,
the vector itself, r1, 2,
divided over the
magnitude of the vector.
We can write it like this.
And now we can write down
the gravitational law.
So the force on object-- we're
going to look at object two.
The force on object two due to
the interaction between objects
one and two is proportional to
the mass of the two objects--
we already said that
in the beginning--
and the square of the distance
between the two objects.
But what about the direction?
The direction here, we're
looking at object two.
We placed our r-hat unit
vector to point down
but the force is going in
the opposite direction--
so in the negative
r1, 2 hat direction.
So we have to add a minus
here and then our 1, 2 r-hat.
And as it is the case
with most of these laws,
it has a
proportionality constant
and Newton called this capital
G. And G, as we know it today
from experiment, is
6.67 10 to the minus 11.
And then in terms of
units, we have Newton.
Force goes in Newton.
We have mass.
This is kilogram squared
and we have meter squared.
So those are the units.
And if you plug those in, then
the units of the whole equation
will work out.
So let's quickly consider
the force in object one
to see what's
happening over there.
So we have F2, 1 equals minus
G m1 m2 over r1, 2 squared.
And in terms of the
unit vector, we now
have r2, 1 hat here going.
So again, this minus goes
with this unit factor
and that one is pointing here
in the opposite direction
than our force.
So that's all good.
But what we see from this
one here-- and actually
from our diagram already--
that r1, 2 equals minus r2, 1.
And so we see from this
then that actually,
Newton's third law, every
action has an equal and opposite
reaction, is true for
this little setup here,
as well, because the forces
are of opposite direction
and of equal magnitude.